that's all about this list from all we
had you you made this this is Katie
Holmes is in it and she directed it yes
Katie Holmes what's it like working with
her like you spent some time with heard
you get to know Katie Holmes yeah I mean
she I was I hadn't met her before we
work together but you know as a fan of
her and TVs and movies and yeah this was
her directorial debut and if you really
she did a great job I mean she was it
was it's tough to do that and yeah I
will say that one day we were working
together early on and she was drinking a
big gulp you know kind of like a huge
soda and one of those ones you get like
a 70s giant mad really this big and she
was drinking it during the scene and in
between the scenes and four you know
we're doing the scene for a couple of
hours that I thought gosh you know
that's up she was drinking a lot of soda
and so at a certain point I said you
know you're really drinking too much
soda and she just looked at me and she
said Luke I hadn't had a soft drink for
seven and a half years I said you know
what
I oughta just out of mind my own
business I think a good idea for me on
the rest of this film is just let you
direct me and I'll mind my own business
I won't bring that up again yeah it's
like what they say about trial lawyers
like you never ask a question that you
don't know the answer try time do that I
shouldn't be giving health tips you know
well you know you may came from a good
place they came from a good place but
obviously she had a situation there for
a while where that was probably banned
[Applause]
that's what I thought was the situation
that you stumbled into and you want to
just back out of that case which I did
which I did do you have a habit of
sticking your foot in your mouth is this
something you do where you say something
cuz you seem like again I gonna say like
something very nice guy but you might
occasionally well yeah I mean I guess
sometimes I don't always think it
through I might be guilty that I mean I
will say that I remember when we first
got started we did this movie bottle
rocket yeah we didn't me and my brothers
own and Andrew did an interview with the
Dallas paper and it was just a
questionnaire that they asked each one
of us you know different questions like
you know favorite Dallas sports team and
favorite restaurant and one of the
questions was favorite favorite time of
day and my brother Andrew said you know
spending time with his friends and Owen
said being with his family and my I
answered morning coffee alone and I mean
it did look kind of final in print but
you know my whole family went crazy our
typical Luke his favorite time of day is
morning alone yeah it smells like Oh
insane like time with my family well
that's I was saying like these guys I
answered it honestly these guys are
answering it like they're running for
the the Senate friends and family yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you